these things that popped off the pager I
was like reading in between the lines I
was like this character is I couldn't
even she was like one word too hot to
put a finger on because like I don't
even know she'll burn me like it was
just like oh but became already this
very visual thing and also to be able to
play a fairy which was kind of again and
crossing all these things of like
sexuality and again talking about the
immigrant and you know crisis and
everything else going on like there was
just so much depth in her and so much
possibility for emotion and
vulnerability but also with strength and
compassion and there were just so many
elements of her where on these two pages
I was like there are so there's so much
to go off here like I just if I don't
get the role I've been thinking about it
still to this day anyway for me as a kid
when there was any hatred towards anyone
it made no sense
and especially you know growing up as
someone who is queer in some way always
feeling like why would anyone judge
anyone for not understanding or not
really knowing them and it never made
sense and also for me like obviously
understanding and not knowing that much
about especially the situations you
don't really know about the refugee like
crisis or the what they what anyone goes
through until you really see it
firsthand so you can feel empathy and
you can understand or try to and kind of
find out as many information as possible
but until you really go there you know
we've both done you know some work there
but it's it's it's crazy because going
to a place like Uganda right which is
one of the you know has one of the less
off countries in the world yeah they
open their arms completely to South
Sudan during the Civil War and they're
every single person they possibly could
not only survive and help them but
thrive as well and then you look at some
of the richest countries in the world
who literally are trying to shut out
people who by the way most of those
countries immigrants have made are
people who are the most successful and
I'm making those countries so what what
I don't understand there's no there's no
follow through on any of these reasons I
think it's grounded so much in reality
like you know when I read it I was like
okay this is a crazy world but but when
I when we when I talked about it it was
it's very rooted in reality and all
those characters feel very real and and
whilst their faith their human eyes
those things